thank you being in that mass that was  huge were you hot I don't was hotter  than oh yeah it was like so hot yeah so  kind of uncomfortable but I wanted to be  in that mask and I wanted to be in that  hard dress oh and those pumps man you  are braver than I look at myself I'm  like I feel like sausage I feel like I'm  stuffed in here help me out I'm ready  no but my sister my mother loved that  show I've gotta cuz of all the jobs we  will ever it's so big it's so popular  yes it is I'm happy to have been a part  of it at 75 I do things that people  don't think 75  yes I have zero time for you looking  like that at 75 Thank You sandy right  now I will not stop talking until you  subscribe to my youtube channel that's  right and I could talk a lot seriously  not gonna stop yep still here not going  anywhere I see you don't walk away from  this